and some pretty blanket statements
saying feminists don't care about it and
you say you think that all women just
are against the men well to answer your
question yeah you're talking about women
women are not all feminists
yeah step forward if you agree with the
prompt
if you're a woman you should be a
feminist
I think the concept of anti-feminism is
like counter-intuitive as a woman like
everyone should want equality of sexes
you know everyone should want to have
the same education level the same all
these things in the position and still
make as much as a person who identifies
as male in this Society we have to be
feminists as women because there's
certain things going on where our rights
are being Stripped Away and black women
black Trans women are more likely to be
murdered and uh and attacked and that's
absolutely a feminist issue and that's
something that everyone should care
about everyone about any gender
expression men included should be
feminists they're I think there are
different
brands of feminism if you will that that
don't represent what I think all of us
here feel is is the true ideal of what
absolutely and I don't think that
everyone has to be active as a feminist
in the exact same way like not everybody
can March not everybody can protest not
everybody can really be an advocate for
feminism at the end of the day it's it's
taking a look at patriarchal systems and
seeing the flaws in those systems and
how they negatively impact
everyone I pause on that thought and the
disagree or step forward
Define woman
go please it's one of you a person who
their internal an idea of what they are
is a woman terrible definition coming
from a lesbian that destroys the very
concept of our sexual orientation just
saying that it's in a why why why
because you can't have you can't be
connected and sexually attracted to
somebody's brain let's make sure to keep
it to the prompt if you're a woman you
should be a feminist why do y'all okay
okay I completely disagree you know
exactly two years ago if you had if I
had done this I probably would be a
feminist but then I started to look at
and I think you they agree as actually
mentioned is like what do black women
gain from feminism because I remember
even during black lives matter when I
led two protests for black women and I
counted how many times how many white
women I saw there and the ones who were
there who were just there to take
pictures for social media and then the
black men also hiding behind us everyone
the whole world hides behind behind
black woman enough same thing that's
happening look what's happening in Iran
people people on the feminist side right
now are not speaking up for those
Iranian women I have a friend that is
trans woman living in Iran right now
it's miserable nobody stands up for that
poor girl as a woman I particularly
think I'm a humanist for example two
years ago I was a region feminist and I
made a decision to Pivot my platform
search black women how to sit in our
feminine energy because we've never
experienced that well that just sounds
like black feminism to me teaching women
how to do that in the time that we are
in now but we're not learning fast
enough we deserve to rest we deserve to
relax we deserve to choose we want to be
a traditional wife I went from law to
being a CEO to now I just want to be a
housewife and every time I say that I
get so much hate like women work so hard
to get to this point why do you want to
be a housewife because because that's
what you want that's what you want
is all about Choice exactly what can I
choose that's the whole point of
feminism it's like why can I choose what
are you missing in America to claim that
you are oppressed as a woman well we
just had our rights to our own uterus is
stripped away all the way to murder your
own baby though I mean it's not a baby
it's a clump of cells I mean we all are
I think cells right here I think
everybody's going to agree and disagree
yeah that's a lot I don't know if that's
about the topic that's not the topic I
had a very very hard time not stepping
up to that prompt because my whole life
I did consider myself a feminist seeing
how this modern wave of feminism has now
turned into something very different
than equal rights we all want equal of
course we want equal rights we want
equality as women of course but how can
you have equal rights when you can't
Define the word woman on the far left
Alta had a woman's day recently and the
women's day was celebrated by two trans
women who still had their male parts I
mean you're you're pushing woman out of
Womanhood I'm sure we're gonna have
discussions about whether or not a trans
woman is woman I actually want to go
back to how
we feel that our ideal of feminism is
probably not the way that you four think
of feminism I'm willing and I I agree
with that and I think that's why people
like me stepped away from that not
because we're not women empowered or
believe in women because we are women
empowered it's because we believe women
in power means something different than
what you guys believe in and what I've
seen now pause there we're going to
reset next prompt there's no wrong
reason to get an abortion
mm-hmm
all right if you were making a health
decision between you and a medical
professional that is the right decision
for you your body your future it is
always the right decision I would never
stand between anyone with a uterus from
making a decision about their body no
yeah they're like you can do it you can
have this health
um you can have this health care if you
are a victim of incest or a victim of
rape it's like you should be able to
have access to that what what if you
want it you know it's about it's the
same as going into the doctor and
getting a routine check if there's
something for your body that you think
will you know not just benefit you but
help you live and also help you sustain
an actual good life for your child then
that's that's what you need to do and
yeah Financial is a huge thing too it is
it's an extremely huge financial
responsibility to have a kid and some
people just don't have that means I I
agree in District I'm definitely
pro-choice I'm probably the only anti
feminist that's pro-choice being
pro-choice pro-abortion is actually very
common it's like 78 of them okay so
there's actually many people who are in
your Academy to me it makes sense in
certain circumstances I don't think
people should be using uh abortion as a
form of birth control I think to me
abortions believe it or not not even the
issue we need to be talking about right
now I feel like we need to be talking
about how to properly educate people no
matter what their their you know
statuses no matter what their sexual
orientation whatever
um and we need to go from there
well I think I have a very interesting
perspective on this because my mother
opened the first Planned Parenthood in
our state and she is very pro-abortion
outwardly
but inwardly in our home we weren't
allowed to do it and so growing up at
that that dichotomy really I think
messed me up a lot because I was like
okay which one is the truth there are
wrong reasons to get an abortion a wrong
reason to get an abortion is if you are
going through your pregnancy and all of
a sudden you change your mind if you are
irresponsible and and uh and and all of
a sudden finding yourself scared of
motherhood when people say that they
don't that women are getting abortions
because they just don't want to be
pregnant anymore they're not actually
understanding the way that an abortion
works most of the time they're talking
about late-term abortions and what a lot
of people don't realize is when you have
that kind of abortion you have to give
birth to the fetus there's no going back
you're literally giving birth to a body
it's never just a whoop I don't feel
like being pregnant anymore guess these
last eight months I just wasted
everything no no one's doing that
raising children is the Most Blessed
gift and I am I I speak as someone who
when I found out that I was expecting
for the first time I kid you not I was
terrified but you were prepared no no no
no no no no no no no no I was not
necessarily prepared I was not prepared
and I was very much caught off guard and
I was terrified because I had an
incredible career happening for me on
the upswing finally I had
let me finish I had such a dramatic
fearful reaction to becoming a mother
because of what our society has been
telling me for my throughout my
adolescence and my early 20s is that
once you become a mother it's all over
and it ends and that is a very very
deeply rooted problem in our society
that I do think we need to address that
sentiment is the patriarchy in action
though what is the patriarchy
what isn't the patriarchy I feel like
that's the better question it's a
systemic
ideal
that favors
masculinity
men male power male dominance the the
traditional idea of what a man is
the patriarchy is a system that
oppresses not just women but everyone
it's not patriarchy because the people
who scared me so much were the women
just because it's coming from a woman
coming from women it does not mean but
these were the No No these were the
women and I do I speak with with really
strong conviction about this the women
who are publicly outward speaking to
other women through blogs through social
media talking about my life is so hard
because of my kids oh my kids are jerks
oh life is this I have no money that
that those messages are very very
pervasive and they're very dangerous and
they're toxic but there are also real
parts of motherhood we just discussed
how much how many of you are mothers
here
I am not a mother but okay I am a mother
of 12 years
and I know all of the very very hard
parts of motherhood and I just wish as
someone who has actually as the only
person here who has gone through this
motherhood experience I from the bottom
of my heart wished that the positive
aspects of motherhood supersede all of
the hard stuff let's get back on prompt
again there's no wrong reason to get an
abortion I wanna I wanna hear from
Isabella there's been so many points I
want to talk about talk about Candace
maybe Candace what she says about I
don't even know what she's oh just let
her talk sorry
um so my parents actually had me when
they were 19 and think thank God they
didn't abort me they were not ready they
were in a terrible situation and having
me at 19 made them grow up and mature
and become adults and not continue being
on a bad path so I'm thankful for that
and a lot of I mean something that you
said you said it's society's I think it
was about societies pushing this idea
like demonizing motherhood and you said
that's part of the patriarchy well I
would ask you this don't you think men
benefit from women getting abortions
because they no longer have to deal with
it they can just sleep around and if God
forbid a woman gets pregnant oh she
wants to abort it cool now I'm off the
hook what what is the patriarchy I don't
even know what that meant a process and
likes did everything that goes wrong
that men are to blame and I don't think
that's a healthy way of being very happy
to live under this so-called patriarchy
this word patriarchy it it does not make
any sense to me women are not oppressed
in America patriarchal society doesn't
bother me like Marilyn Monroe says as
long as I can be all of a woman in it I
am not bothered
the feminist movement is inherently
racist
the feminist movement does not benefit
POC
in any shape or form it especially does
not benefit black women and the darker
your skin is the more you are used I
call us black women as the bullets for
the feminist movements if we're talking
historically if we're if we're talking
how feminist movements started it was an
exclusionary movement if we go back to
the suffragettes or even further black
women were not allowed to join in that
effort because they really weren't
fighting so we were used as bullets
right they were not being used we can't
be part of the movement they did use
black women they used black women's
efforts because most of the most
achievements that feminism you're right
like most of the achievements of
feminism have been done by black women
and white women have stepped in and take
the correct and taken incredibly for
like people who do identify as feminists
especially those of us who are white I
think the most important thing for us to
do is to sit down shut up and listen to
black women
as a black woman who identifies as a
feminist my work centers black women so
to say that you know of course like
white women were able to vote before
black women like the feminist movement
was inherently racist but how I live my
life in the way that I the community
that I've built around myself of black
feminists we see I label it feminism
whatever you want but helping other
black women I affirm you and I don't see
that the semantics makes you
uncomfortable because feminism was
racist but you it is still racist but
you're not racist so if if you are not
racist and you have issues that you want
to be working towards for black women
that doesn't mean that you're inherently
being racist or helping white women I
think feminism exists on a spectrum
you're talking about semantics we're
talking about terms they evolve and they
change ideologies change right and I
think that feminism is evolving and
changing and I think it's because of the
work of people like you and and so
that's why I can confidently say it's
evolving it's not evolving I think it's
devolving you know I think third word
third wave feminism I mean by all
accounts I see you know again have a
very powerful black mother a very
feminist black mother and I mean no one
wants to say they did life wrong but
she's saying man I wish I could have
taken care of myself I wish I could have
done this and I love how you get your
hair done and you go get makeup done and
you're so and I and she says it you know
like she wasn't there in the household
to raise us like you went back to
Motherhood because she was gone fighting
every single day for women's rights to
come home and be exhausted by time she
gets home and we never got to have a
mother you know when I scroll my own
social media feed I rarely rarely rarely
see a powerful woman highlighted who is
not in ethnicity
I yes no no I I it's it's true I'm using
them as pawns 100 a lot of big brands
are now hopping on this you know modern
feminism bandwagon
um which I I don't agree with what
modern feminism is uh but um a lot of
Brands now
and I'll just say you know a big brand
that comes to mind is dove
diversity is always a good thing however
I have for years have not seen
any kind of a ad campaign from the brand
Dove speaking to women's empowerment
that does that that includes
a woman that looks like us what modern
feminism today is lacking I think is
genuine respect for diversity of pin of
opinion for all women
if you felt modern day feminism didn't
hijack all points of view of women that
you would still identify as a feminist
yes
yes well I mean the entire time everyone
was talking all I was thinking was wow
I'm so sick of all these labels and all
these different intersections and these
days there's more intersections than
genders and I'm just like all these
identity politics groups were just
pitting each other against each other I
like race keeps getting brought up I
know it's brought up in the prompt for
this one but in every single other one
and I don't even think about this I
don't even think that I'm not being
represented even in ads I don't care it
just does I don't I'm sure I am me I'm
literally yeah I'm sure you don't care
you don't have to Care thank you for
letting me know that you always a
feminist always know best for me that's
what I've noticed it's a trend but I
mean I'm just pointing out that you are
a privileged white woman who has not had
to see the lack of diversity when we
step into a room filled with other white
people we don't notice that it's other
white people but when women of color
have stepped into rooms and they see
that it's just a bunch of other white
people also intersectionality is not
just about diversity and it's certainly
not about diversity and AD campaigns
it's about how poor women can afford to
drive to another state to get an
abortion but rich women can it costs
more money to drive to get an abortion
than it would take to raise that kid
but that's the thing right like if you
don't have the money to drive to get an
abortion how are you going to have the
money to raise that child why should you
be supportive
feminists don't appreciate all that men
do for society
I've got a lot to say about this I mean
feminists I mean feminists just demonize
men they hate men all men are trash you
say they hate men while simultaneously
trying to become men they hate them for
having power and the patriarchy so
they're trying to overtake it but a lot
of women will talk about rape culture
but guess what guess who's going to
protect you from bad people a man
we need men it's as simple as that it's
a god-given right for men to exist the
way they were assigned to exit we need
men it's it's it's very simple we need
men to procreate when you're meant to
provide we need men to produce we didn't
meant to go to war and die we need man
it's so bad now that men can they're so
scared of us they're terrified all the
time I go on dates with a man they're
like am I allowed to open the door can I
open the door can I touch it can I pull
the chair out what can I do and they're
shaking they're sweating and you're just
like be yourself just it's okay you like
they're so afraid of doing anything
wrong so much so they're they're not the
most lonely demographic in the world
right like the straight white straight
white man I heard they're not the most
lonely because they just created in
cells you know they don't want to leave
their apartment or their house because
they're so afraid of women I I really
I'm not on board with this trend
especially happening in schools right
now there is a trend where they are
raising up the girls girl power girl
boss girl this you know run like a girl
in the best way makes me vomit that's
now now it's dangerous it is dangerous
because yes we want to uplift our women
that's the right thing to do so that men
and women do maintain equality but at
the same time by raising the girls
raising the girls we are forgetting
about our boys yeah they want to solve
inequality by enforcing more inequality
and if women were equal to men then why
do the girls need to be raised up so
much
why the only men that feminists like are
men dressing as women in dominating
their Sports and just really reversing
what the other waves of feminism thought
to do have fun with men beating you and
your sports women because guess what
you're not going to beat them have fun
I've never even felt unequal so I don't
even know what the problem is I feel
like a lot of people just want to have a
reason to be upset and outraged I also
just don't identify with all these
identity politics groups I think because
they're being pit against each other
separating all these different people by
race class gender everything sexual
orientation and I look at people as
individuals all right on that note let's
have the disagree or step forward
there's a difference between not
appreciating men and pointing out the
inequities that have been
systemically put in place to favor men
especially white men white straight men
there's a difference between hating men
and pointing out that there are
inequities I want to talk about this
concept of protection we're talking
about Good Men good men who are
protectors who are they protecting us
from the bad men bad men exactly or bad
women bad anybody I could because I have
a car and it was a rhetorical I guess no
I understand the point you were trying
to make that's why I said but I'm going
to finish so then who benefits from
Men's bad behavior
good men as well right they get to be
positioned as the good guys Good Apples
they're the Good Apples and that is
predicated on the bad behavior of men no
they benefit from being a good person
and protecting women who care it's not a
we should not be praising People based
off comparing them to bad people but I
don't benefit from being a good girl I
don't know you're a good feminist right
I'm sure people love what you have to
say as a feminist other feminists agree
with it and they're like yes go go girl
people on Earth and bad people on Earth
we're always going to have that that
would never change it's in every animal
kingdom so we need the good man to
protect us from the Batman to go off of
what you said because you said when
women are sexually assaulted they turn
to another man to protect them I work as
a sexual assault in domestic violence
counselor I work with rape victims every
single day they don't turn to men to
protect them they don't I need to return
to them I was saying no they potentially
can if you're walking home alone at
night I don't train them to another man
I don't I turn to other women yeah I
appreciate men like I love a man that
knows his place build it build the house
yeah yeah repair that because I'm a
goddess like if you you you need to hold
your weight in the relationship like I
appreciate men I love men like you know
just like you said you know you have a
husband you want to cook for your
husband you make sure that he's good men
have roles in society as well feminists
is anything you want it to be as a woman
I am promiscuous because I'm a feminist
but you can also be conservative because
I'm a feminist modern day feminism is
about you and what you make it and not
what someone 60 years ago said it was
but I don't praise men because they
aren't raping like you know
yeah
same exact pain with my prompt because I
I do appreciate me and I don't think
that feminists don't appreciate men I
don't I think that's that's not true
like the person who taught me to be the
feminist that I am was my father my
father did not raise me to believe that
I was less than because I was a woman he
raised me to understand that I am
societally disadvantaged but he told me
that I was going to rise above that my
house with my father my mom was so
strong My dad became so emasculated he
cannot do anything he stopped working he
became just like a couch potato right
why she just went out there and kill it
and we are destroying family as we know
because look at me I'm in my 30s I'm not
settled down I don't have children I
don't have this family unit that I want
so terribly because no matter how hard I
try that feminism that I was raised with
always tends to over Shadow my
relationships in my head I know best
right like I know what's right I know so
I saw it growing up I saw it modeled to
me growing up like a woman knows
everything we're so powerful they are so
strong men are supposed to be the head
of the household do you understand that
that is killing men that's killing men
it is killing me one of them die because
we need to get they need to go back to
working the pressure of it you mean
right the pressure the pressure of it is
destroying their mental health that's
why men are six times more likely to
commit suicide than women are especially
men in committed relationships men in
their 40s that are married with families
are the highest risk for suicide but
it's killing men because but it's
killing men because we have generations
and generations of boys who were not
raised to be men and rise to that
occasion it's killing men because we are
not in a position capitalistically where
we can have men be the one single head
of the household the bread earner the
decision maker we are no longer in the
1950s our economy is not able to handle
that kind of that kind of nuclear family
with the man being the head of the
household the stay-at-home moms and the
and the 2.5 children I want to clarify
I'm not a stay-at-home mom no no I knew
work so I do have perspective when you
are in a long-term marriage or
relationship with a partner of anyone
yes you're going to have disagreements
but you you also have to understand that
each person in that partnership does
have roles because that is how a healthy
family functions
only women should make laws about
women's bodies
I'm going to add a minor caveat to this
and not say that like entirely just
women should make laws about women's
bodies and I think it's more important
that people who are educated on the
female body are the people who are
allowed to make laws about the female
body like we shouldn't have lawmakers
making laws stating oh abortion is
completely completely illegal even if
it's an ectopic pregnancy you can you
can reinsert that fetus no you're
killing people if you if you make that
kind of stupidness law it doesn't mean
that any of our male lawmakers can't be
involved and frankly I think they need
to be a little bit more involved some of
them yes they are letting me down and
you know I think there are a lot of men
who hold a lot of power who are on our
side who are not doing enough yeah
I want to say it's funny because I think
you all spoke for us because I think you
all agreed that everyone should be
involved in making these laws we need
men you see how simple that was and men
can be women these days men can't be
women if they actively identify as men
that that's not a thing I currently
identify as a man okay then you're a man
congratulations thank you do you agree
that these laws that are specific about
our bodies shouldn't The Originators of
that bill talking about our bodies be
women answer that can y'all no I think I
I don't think we should think about men
versus women I think we should have
intelligence men versus women of course
men are going to be involved with
creating laws and putting laws into
place but when we're talking about the
language when we're talking about
verbiage for these laws shouldn't a
woman be multiple women preferably be
involved yeah be at the Forefront of
what these laws look like for us I think
I think I think it's less about a man
versus a woman and more about the way
Society is now versus 50 years ago
people that you didn't even vote for
that are that are spending lifelong
terms in Congress and such you know
that's that's in the Supreme Court
that's that's more of an issue to me
than worrying about if a man or a woman
wrote this law or a bill which checks
and balances to our government checks I
wanted to ask you
um would you I'm a woman I'm 100
pro-life oh you're a woman now
very fluid very fluid by the hour but
um would you be okay with some a woman
now for now and I am very pro-life
you're okay with women like me making
these laws because you disagree with the
outcome there I don't know your choice
right but the law the law is if we're
talking about Roe v Wade right yeah the
law the law is about it's not about your
ideal pro-life it's about abortion it's
about bodily autonomy if you don't want
to get an abortion fine that I mean
that's what it's all about it's your
choice I wanna I wanna sort of reverse
it and ask you the question should there
be laws about women's bodies where there
was no women involved
because there certainly are
right but we live in a system of
government where there are states rights
and I live in California and guess what
I don't agree with anything our governor
is doing I don't agree with the majority
that is in our state legislature yet I
live here and I choose to live here and
if I have a problem with the laws then I
have the opportunity to move to a
different state so just all the
people who don't have the opportunity to
move to a difference everyone has
opportunity to work to make a life for
themselves here in America they don't
love about America is that this is the
only place on Earth that you can work
and Achieve based on your marriage I was
raised by a single mom who you know
didn't have the support she needed to
really mother me so by the time I was 15
I moved out of her home and I lived with
a boyfriend at the time I fought my
school board for better sex education I
fought my Senator when he voted to
repeal funding for title 10 and birth
control access the funding I relied on
and I told him
why would you deny me the American dream
and I shared with him that birth control
was helping me to be successful to go on
to higher education and now I'm on a
full ride at Columbia University I'm the
first my family to go to college and in
large part that is because of access to
birth control you guys mentioned that
you know there's not everyone has a
bootstrap and this is why a feminism is
such a weird topic to have in this
particular country because I'm from a
development I'm a Nigeria you know
although my parents were quite
successful thankfully but I grew up
around poverty I saw it every single day
and so to come to this country to have
to start over and make something of
ourselves and I see immigrants do it all
the time when you say things like oh I
was raised by a single mother or you
know most people don't have bootstraps
you're in America
that's like this is I mean this is the
place this is the place to do it find
that boots honey and put it on no one's
saying that there aren't challenges
we're saying that this is the best place
to have that challenge and I quickly
want the challenges are not distributed
equally nobody says let me just somebody
did to say that only women should make
decisions about women's bodies is
completely unrealistic I have to believe
that there is a future where that is
possible well of course there's future
more women than ever aren't serving in
our government of course there's a
future so of course women always have a
seat at the table you're at Columbia
what are you you moved on to 15 year at
Columbia yeah you know when I graduated
from UC Berkeley and I was in my lecture
halls there were two other black people
and it's 400 people in here like that
makes me uncomfortable it's not that we
look at everything through an oppressive
lens it's that many of us hold different
identities that allow Society to
continue to oppress us a friend of mine
had to travel across state for an
abortion she had the ability to select
between paying for her disability the
things that she needs for her disability
or traveling for an abortion like you
guys don't have to think about that she
asked her decision to have sex
no Then I then with you then I agree
with you okay
but I shouldn't have to tell you that
story for you to understand that there
are certain things that you have not
experienced that oppress other people oh
okay you're just traumatized enough for
me to understand that maybe things are
hard feminism that doesn't include trans
women isn't feminism
you surprised to see me here
okay good you know it's really important
to include trans women and trans people
and gender non-conforming people which
by the way I am gender queer myself I
don't actually identify as a woman it's
really important that those of us who do
have privileges like speak up for trans
women in the in in the community
especially because they're the most at
risk for hate crimes I also want to just
level set and say that we are having
this conversation without trans women
right we are sitting here today for sure
I I identifying hold on my identifies is
non-binary and she's on my she's my
feminist pan my pronoun so maybe she
doesn't belong here either they don't
belong here plot twist I am biologically
female and I'll never deny that I lived
as a woman for most of my life
um I am 31 I only came out a couple of
years ago I spent a lot of time you know
the majority of my life in these spaces
with women that does give me a kind of
unique perspective now being a trans
non-binary person there's an issue with
categorizing uh Womanhood as a means of
female earlier it was mentioned by
somebody on the other on the anti-trans
side about trans women coming in and
taking over Sports and things like that
which is just not true that is true it's
not it is I can show you number I can
show you there might be people that also
have it no I remember you
once women retain 30 of their biological
advantages
it is that is yes it is that is not
arguing that's not even the prompts I'm
not going to argue about that because
you're wrong if you are a trans woman
and you walk out in the world and you
are seen as a man you do not belong in
women's spaces I don't care what anybody
says I think that's ridiculous and I
think even trans women that have gender
dysphoria that go through transition
will agree with me this makes me so
incredibly uncomfortable that we're even
having this conversation let's go back
over there if you really wanted to oh if
we took all of that off the table right
if we're not talking about who can play
sports with whom do do can people exist
as who they are absolutely it sounded
like you were saying if a trans woman
doesn't look like what you perceive as
looking like a woman they shouldn't be
in feminist spaces I didn't say that I
said they shouldn't be in female spaces
okay not feminist spaces okay I think
women I disagree with that but that's
fine it makes sense to biologically
classify people it also makes sense to
socially classify people let's say my
friend Blair white was sitting right
here as my buddy I love her she's
sitting right here do I think she lives
her life as a man no like we were
talking about men making
decisions for women as far as abortions
are concerned that's something she'll
never experience there are women who
biologically cannot produce that are
females people assign female at Birth
who biologically cannot produce are you
saying that those female women should
not be able to to have say in those laws
that's not what I'm saying at all I
guess my main issue with trans women
being seen as women and not being seen
as trans women is they're changing the
definition of women and expecting
everybody to go along with that and that
affects me thus they are and that
affects me directly you say trans women
are women trans women are trans women
it's a very different experience women
are women we're just going to agree to
disagree with that if you ask feminists
at a women's March what a woman is they
can't even Define it how can you protect
something and Empower something that you
don't even know the actual definition of
well I will say JK Rowling calls herself
a feminist and was canceled for not
being pro-trans and which is kind of
overtaking and reversing some of the
work feminists have done in the past
she's a billionaire well they criticize
her fine because she's fine
feelings are hurt I'm so saddened for
her feminist movement does not allow
anyone to have any other opinions but
what you guys know because she's allowed
to have that opinion and she still makes
a bunch of money yes she does what do
trans women take away from women in the
feminist movement the definition of
words and what that means and how that
affects us directly when you change you
expand on that yes when you change the
word woman legally it has implications
sexually it has implications
directly changed throughout histories
throughout different cultures indigenous
people have had different uh different
genders different uh different ways of
looking at gender the Torah specifically
has eight different genders and we have
recognized that for over three thousand
years you're denying anybody's culture
that does not agree with your perception
and your world view because you hold so
highly onto your identity and you see it
as an attack on
sexual orientation but it's nothing to
do with sexual it has exactly to do it's
like when you change the word woman and
a lesbian is a woman that is attracted
to women how is that not directly
affecting us
what defines a woman
is being born with biological women's
parts
and that is what a woman is and trans
women are individuals who choose to live
their lives as women and and and I I and
I honor that and everyone everyone
deserves dignity and respect and I mean
that but at the same time there are
Universal truths and we have as a
society gotten to this confusing tangle
place where there's your truth Your
Truth Your Truth Your Truth there is one
objective truth in what we are can you
explain to me the women in Guatemala who
are born female who are assigned female
at Birth and then during puberty grow
penises I've never I can't explain it
because I don't know anything that
sounds like an intersex condition you
try to again but how feminist always
tries to tell us how we should live our
life I said I was already feminist she
goes I don't believe that I don't see
that I don't and what you've been saying
I can't see any traces of feminism in my
mother is literally we've heard a lot
about your mom but what about shoes I am
a woman looking at me I am a woman born
and raised a woman why are we trying to
right woman born biological women why
are you trying to write us out of
History you guys keep saying that
there's a biological reality of male and
female scientists do not agree with you
scientists that you choose to agree with
I mean you can find a study and a
scientists back up anything you want to
well I choose to do peer-reviewed
studies and not ones that are backed by
political agenda and I'm sorry that my
peer-reviewed studies tend to agree with
the fact that trans women are women and
that biology it does not exist in a
binary never has and it never will
I secretly crave men's approval
yeah
men's approval has kept me safe in so
many ways being desirable being
has kept me safe many a time and it's no
secret I guess that's where I disagree
it's no secret that sometimes men's
approval is what stands between me and
safety I firmly believe that the reason
why I waited so long to come out with my
transness is because I was afraid of
losing male approval it is so embedded
into our society I really pushed myself
to present in a way that wasn't
authentic to me for men
I'm trying to unlearn this like very
actively and trying to fight for
nobody's approval but myself like
because it's not even that I should have
men's approval or I should mean men's
approval or women's approval I should
need my own approval yeah and I think I
mean this prompt I think might be
surprising for some folks to see us
sitting here because we're like so
feminist but like kids are reminded that
this work doesn't happen in a vacuum and
that because I am implicated in what is
happening right in the issues I am
implicating the issues that's why I do
the work yeah because I am impacted by
them
foreign
I wish that man would find me sexy
because I feel so empowered in myself I
always dress like this from head to toe
covered usually from head to toe and
never I don't think I've ever
experienced a woman perhaps
subconsciously but I don't think I've
ever and you know I think that's also
why you know with my platform now that I
switch from a raging feminist to a
femininity which I was and you can't
tell me what I was and who I was I had
the shaped head the armpit hair all of
it did you really yes I did and when I
went from that to that now I teach women
how to like dress modern and cover up
and be feminine and soft and all of that
who are you dressing modern and modest
for for myself because it makes it
empowers me I am Nigerian first and
foremost and because of that in our
culture we've always been very modest we
didn't even have a word for it it's just
that's that's how women dress we would
layer on top of layers on top of layers
and I remember when I first you know
became a feminist and like movements and
I would show skin I always felt so
uncomfortable why did you feel
uncomfortable with showing your skin I'm
not saying that that's wrong I'm just
asking out of curiosity why you felt
uncomfortable like what the root of that
discomfort was because it's not who I am
but I also think we'd be denying reality
if we said when we put clothes on the
morning we didn't think about the way
that we would navigate the world in them
right the way that people would perceive
us and think about us and it's
definitely worth noting that like you
know clothing choices are also about
access to power access to moving through
spaces being seen as acceptable in
certain spaces right like covering up
not necessarily because you feel like
that empowers you but covering up
because it's a sense of safety like so
many like one of the things that we have
to
um that I with my job we have to correct
officers on like when an assault victim
comes forward like they're not allowed
to ask what were you wearing like but
that's but it's because it's very bad
it's very
um it's very dehumanizing because it
implies that it was their fault that it
was their fault I think we can all agree
on that yeah I just don't really care
about me and like men are not a part of
my day when I wake up in the morning I
think about how to be the baddest
um how to step into myself so if that's
looking like you from head to toe or
showing a little cleavage like it's
gonna be what it is and men are gonna
like the men I attract they like me
because I am like no one else they've
met like they they've never really
experienced this new person she's like
you can't you you don't know what their
approval is like especially when it
comes to things like race and and
preference and like nothing that I do is
gonna really be approved by men ever so
I might as well just do me but I do just
want to say that men's approval once
again it's not just about if they want
to date you or marry you or have sex
with you it is about if they want to
hire you if they want you to be a part
of their organization or their school
and so when we talk about wanting men's
approval we're talking about if they
want to hire me if they want to let me
have access to that social mobility and
if they will allow me to be safe walking
down the street or in a bar men's
approval is so much deeper and more
systemic than just than just romantic
yeah are we allowed to I have to agree
with that even though it we're on the
opposite end of this because you know
I'm a blogger and I write about women's
like makeup and you know for example
Dove is one of the brains that I am the
face of and when I go into those
meetings they are white men
and although I do not go into it
thinking oh my God I should seek the
approval I do know that the way I dress
conservatively gets me those checks and
probably as a black woman how you wear
your hair as well oh yeah
but that's also how I was raised and in
my it's cultural Nigerian women are very
conservative by Nature it's rational for
women to fear men
recipe
thank you
working with sexual assault and domestic
violence victims every single day it has
completely just reopened my mind and my
trauma because I am a sexual assault
Survivor myself which is why I got into
the work that I do
um it's every single woman almost like
almost every single woman has some sort
of story where she was in a room or in a
space with a man and that man made her
feel unsafe
And if every single woman has a story
like that it's rational absolutely
and I think that's why again I know I'm
bringing this back to the trans issue
but that's again why I think it's
important to Define what a woman or man
or male or female is like if if it's
just something in your head then why do
we logically have to be afraid of that
specific thing if it's just something a
gender in your head so there are
biological differences that can make us
fearful or make men react certain ways
that are different than women yes
but there's absolutely a different
perception of a trans woman than a man
like when in my experience when women
are with like in the same room as trans
women they're not as fearful of like oh
my God this person could assault me
because the uh the likelihood of trans
people assaulting women is so
so small like it's practically and
there's no reason there's a reason for
that I agree with that actual trans
women my point trans women period not
actual or in actual no there is a thing
people that are claiming the trans
identity against the prompt that's true
men are not only scary because of their
biological different they're stronger
whatever right some of the violence is
that men can can be abusive harmful and
get away with it absolutely it's the
systemic power that's right the reason
that 90 90 of sexual assault cases go
unreported is because of like roughly
the eight percent that are reported only
two percent of them actually face
consequences
some are some of my deepest I honestly
would say probably my deepest trauma is
actually not my physical sexual assault
it was the
manipulation that I faced after in the
work no in the workplace by someone who
was not
necessarily physical with me but they
manipulated me they used their power to
paint me in a light
and push me out of that job that I loved
I'm so sorry you experienced that I
agree like the stats will say a trans
woman which I would say is a man a trans
woman
is less likely like very unlikely to
attack but it's not even it's really
kind of the principle it's like but if
they were to
they would beat me up but then I'm gonna
take that one step further which is that
if they were to
and then the police were to come what
would their experience be like versus
yours white woman I'm not talking about
the cops it just means a factor I
actually hate the cops I don't like cops
if you see a male person and you see a
trans woman like what does that have
equal amounts of fear for you or is
there a difference so my thing I'm
trying to focus in on a trans woman
wants to beat me up why are trans women
wanting to beat you up that's not that's
something
it's a hypothetical I'm just saying like
can we all agree that I would get my ass
beat but I'm sorry yes or no I mean yes
maybe but then how would the experience
be outside of just that hypothetical
value
is my thought because that's not the
prompts though no but it is the prompt
we're talking about we can't talk about
this in a hypothetical what's the
problem The Prompt was that it's
rational for women to fear men but
you're bringing in trans women when the
discussion is men right this reality for
me it's about power and that's what I'm
saying is that that's what you are and
that's what I'm saying is that that
situation is so unlikely and it is
unlikely because of the difference in
societal power that you hold over a
trans woman that's not exactly for
people who love to us who I understand
who love to criticize other people for
assuming genders incorrectly you love
assuming how things are going to happen
and like predict the future and how
situations play out and how I'm treated
by everyone else well you're hypothetic
that's a hypothetical you're also
assuming what would happen to me I why
are you like you're assuming they would
beat you up a man would beat me up yes a
man you're assuming a trans woman
yes
you want to avoid answering that part in
going to this bigger broad thing
question
if there was a biological man a trans
woman
I disagree with you on the definition
here biological male but I am a man
we'll say male or female and gender man
I'm a biological woman who is roughly of
like not too big of a difference of size
I could easily beat you right so why are
you more afraid of them than me when I I
present just as equal of a difference to
you it's because of your no you you
obviously could be no because because
no you said this five minutes ago men
males not men necessarily males create
would you say 90 of would you say males
create 90 of the crimes
um I didn't say that there was something
like that I said I was talking about
reports of sexual assault and that does
actually include male assault victims
and most most of them are males and most
of the males that's my victims their
assaulters were also men that's my point
right
hi okay so let's start by saying the
conversation that I just listened to I
don't disagree with much of what we were
talking about when this prompt was asked
I interpreted the prompt to say to to
communicate uh it is rational for women
to fear all men I know that the word all
was not in there but that's how I sort
of understood it which I don't think
it's rational for women to fear all men
I think that's very tragic we know that
there are bad men we know that there are
very very good men and I personally
think that the amount of Good Men uh
exceedingly overwhelms the amount of
badmin but that's just my personal
opinion I also quite frankly
fear women I do I fear how manipulative
women can be to each other in the
workplace I fear how manipulative women
can be to each other and how toxic women
can be to each other when it comes to
polarizing topics like we've discussed
here motherhood other very incendiary
topics we're talking about physical
abuse with men and and actually with
emotional abuse it's most common in
lesbian couples yeah that is yeah
it's horrendous horrendous women are
equally as likely to commit domestic
violence I I genuinely when I got into
this work I thought that it was going to
be like oh just men commit domestic
violence no women women aren't really as
likely to commit domestic but why were
you surprised by that
um because I I had a different
definition in my head of what domestic
violence was before I got my training
domestic violence is not just
punching hitting or physical violence
oftentimes it's uh emotional violence
psychological violence sexual violence
Financial violence legal violence and
women are far more likely to commit
psychological domestic violence or
emotional domestic violence oh why were
you with your original definition the
more violent definition of domestic
violence yeah physical violence why were
you surprised that oh women
like I wasn't surprised
no I wasn't surprised that women commit
physical violence uh physical domestic
violence I assumed that under the Dem
like I assumed that there was one
definition of domestic violence and that
was physical and statistics do show that
men do commit physical domestic violence
more than women do yeah yeah that's just
a fact but like when you when you add in
all other kinds of domestic violence
women committed at equal rates yeah
that's a wrap on the group discussion
take a breath for a second I do
appreciate the ways in which we have
been able to come together and agree
because I am of the opinion that
feminism and anti-feminism they they do
oftentimes blend because I think a lot
of the times we are misunderstanding
what the other person's we all want
what's good for women that's what I said
over there
for a woman yes but we all want the best
for each other even if I disagree I love
strong women I love it it's not a gay
thing maybe
and all of our intentions are good we're
not we don't want ill that is a wrap on
the group discussion
[Applause]